our traffic anchor nate tannenbaum wore  purple as he was broadcasting from home  this morning for an important cause  he explained what that's about  it is in honor of national pancreatic  cancer  awareness day asking folks to wear  purple to raise awareness  obviously pancreatic cancer has been in  the news a lot with the  death of some high profile folks of  course one of those people he's  referencing is alex trebek who passed  away earlier this month after a battle  with pancreatic cancer  in his honor today jeopardy tweeted out  a picture of him  and his wife jean encouraging people to  raise awareness  and get to know the risks and the  symptoms  the late supreme court justice ruth  bader ginsburg and civil rights icon  representative john lewis also  passed away this year after battles with  pancreatic cancer  you can find out much more information  online just search the nevada  pancreatic cancer awareness network